speaking of average skill sets Molly
Hemingway
and Harris Faulkner at Fox News Harris
Faulkner not part of the uh the the
infotainment the entertainment side of
Fox News but one of their straight
reporters
recently Brian Cranston I know this is
going to seem out of the blue here but
this is what this is about Brian
Cranston recently appeared on Bill
Maher's podcast I can't remember the
name of it
um random things are dumb things or
bigoted things or
I don't I don't remember the name but in
it they started talking about CRT
because Bill Maher is now a useful idiot
or maybe a willing participant in moral
Panic related to critical race Theory
and the the conversation started in and
and Brian Cranston said he thinks that
critical race Theory should be taught to
Children it would be beneficial
where Bill Maher took him to task for
that or disagreed at the very least and
this conversation between Molly
Hemingway a right-wing provocateur and
if Harris Faulkner picks up there but I
wanted to give you the the background
and the context of this clip watch this
after crankson said it ought to be
taught in schools let's pause there and
just go right back to Molly if we could
to get your reaction
yeah well Bill Maher is and Brian
Cranston had this discussion on a
podcast where Cranston says that we have
not done enough to deal with our history
and not enough is being taught I think
Brian Cranston should learn his own
history such as about the Civil War
which was the bloodiest war that we went
through all that has been done to deal
with the you know original sin as people
say of American slavery and we need more
history not the corrupted false sort of
propaganda history that is being pushed
by left-wing activists that teaches
hatred of the country will you and I say
this a lot we need more information in
General on everything and then let
people decide what you know from what
everything they learn how they live
their own lives
I I've always argued the beginning of
freedom is with as much information as a
journalist we both agree to this
as you can possibly have so you can make
the best decisions Molly Hemingway a
pleasure to have you in Focus today
thank you
this should be taught at a graduate
level in a in a a course on hypocrisy
one I hope that you noted the little
chuckle there as Molly Hemingway
referred to slavery as our original sin
you know our original sin chuckle
chuckle nudge nudge joke joke
it was indeed the original sin of this
country
the enslavement of millions of human
beings
for prophet's sake
to to make rich white men in this
country richer
not wider that's not possible but
certainly richer
and for them to laugh it off
is disgusting
but this entire thing about more we need
more history taught not but not the woke
history not CRT history we can't teach
about Jim Crow we can't teach about
redlining we can't teach about slavery
or convict Leasing
or or just the the
voter suppression
an oppression of blacks over the course
of the entirety of white man's existence
on this continent no no no that's CRT
that's dangerous
but they do they say oh more
Harris Faulkner argues for as much
information as possible which is in
direct contravention and contradiction
of of the point that they're trying to
say that not that history
not the history that causes people to
hate America listen
I love my country and because I love my
country I criticize my country I served
for years in the United States Marine
Corps because of some level of
patriotism some love of country
so critic being critical of one's
country it's like being critical of your
family your brother your mother your
father your cousin your uncle it's not
because you hate them
if you have a best friend that does
something that's a little shitty and you
criticize them you don't hate them
if you look back on past relationships
I'm dumbing this down for an audience
that doesn't need it but come on
Molly Hemingway Harris Faulkner
participants in the whitewashing of the
the stashing away in a Cupboard the
parts of American history that they
don't like that make them uncomfortable
they're not able to exist in in the
space that is that is uncomfortable for
them
and we need to as a society create that
space for our children when we teach
them
so they can have two conflicting points
and and deal with it yes you can love
your country
while also acknowledging the wrongs that
we've committed in the past the sins
against our fellow man
because if we don't and we're unable to
we're far more likely to create those
same mistakes and commit those same sins
get it together
Fox News
once again I am Jesse dollar Moore I
host the dollar more daily on YouTube I
host a podcast called I doubt it and uh
you can follow me on social media at
Dollar Moore on Instagram Twitter and
Tick Tock I'd love to see you there